[Music]
hi welcome to the pretty intense podcast
on the show today is an old friend Aaron
Dowdy he is huge on YouTube calling me
YouTube sensation a YouTuber he helps
people expand their Consciousness he
uses everything from law of attraction
to the energetics of things so today was
a kind of a philosophizing conversation
about uh relationships about the
energetics of how things work what it
means when you actually have passion for
something versus doing something and and
what that reality looks like this is
kind of one of those really good Love
Dose days of of hearing a conversation
about being in alignment with yourself
enjoy the show thanks for stopping by
please hit the Subscribe and bell for
notifications when we have shows come
out and let me know what you think about
this episode and let's philosophize in
the comments you're such a you're such
an OG YouTuber I know oh yeah that is
true how many years ago I feel like I
started watching your stuff gosh six or
seven years ago I feel like I was seeing
things I feel like you were talking in
Sedona you would like be bundled up
outside is that right and then you would
be talking about I think things had to
do with kind of a little bit of like
spirituality was there like astrology
even woven into it and like I had I had
broca Goldsmith on recently I don't know
if you know who she is she's like a
famous astrologer that was like a year
ago before that though yeah I mean five
years on YouTube now YouTube such a such
a I love YouTube personally I think it's
just the best way to learn I I do love
how the algorithms just continue to give
you more of like the same kind of stuff
um do you watch YouTube or do you just
put stuff do you just oh no I
I watch YouTube I'm a YouTube fan so I
don't really want I mean I watch
House of dragons and like [ __ ] like that
you know but with YouTube yeah I love
because part of being like being able to
be good on YouTube is being able to
study what's doing well to then learn so
that then I can know how to make better
videos and stuff so most YouTubers for
them to really grow they have to be
obsessed with like learning how to make
good videos and see what else other
people in the space are doing and stuff
like that so I've definitely I watch
YouTube more than anything else for sure
what did you what what is something new
that you're doing that you're like oh I
gotta do more of that uh not make any
videos at all stop it what do you mean I
I have I have made videos for like five
years now five videos seven videos a
week and I'm at a space to where I'm
getting so burnt out from being
repetitive that I haven't made a video
it's only been a week but I'm gonna
eventually go back but I'm gonna go from
five videos a week down to like one
video a week and put more energy into
that one video a week and
um I'm I feel like my calling is to do
more so like Live Events and I've known
that for like two years but YouTube like
has got me so much success and like
security that it's been hard for me to
let go of like the the you know the
daily videos so the next thing is I have
my team we're all focused on like doing
Live Events recording it taking clips
from that putting that on YouTube and
like doing a completely new model just
because
um it's that's what I'm more I know I'm
gonna be more passionate about I've done
Live Events before too and there it's a
completely different energy being in
front of people versus just like getting
in front of a camera and regurgitating
content you know once you've made 2 000
videos it just becomes what else is
there to talk about what else is there
to talk about but also like let's talk
about maybe even like the energetics of
it because you really have loved making
those videos and I know there was some
discipline to sort of make a certain
amount or make them every day or make
them on a certain Cadence but but there
was a love and a passion for that and so
so if that isn't there let's I'm like
curious if you think about the
energetics of the information in the
video If there's not actually like the
frequency of Truth and authenticity and
like real good passion then do you think
that that's a part of it like I'm
curious what your thoughts are around
that and then
um getting into of course the Live
Events and like What feelings come out
for that because feelings are such
they're they're like the the universe
isn't hearing our thoughts or our words
it's our feelings 100 yeah I'm glad you
said that because when in the beginning
when I started making videos back in
2017 I started making daily videos and I
was so passionate about it because it
was so new for me and it was also the
edge of my comfort zone because I was
like afraid to put myself out there in
front of people especially to talk about
esoteric Concepts that were kind of like
you know a little bit different way of
thinking I was afraid of what my friends
would think my family would think
um I was afraid I wasn't credible enough
like all of these doubts came up and
then I started doing it and it became so
rewarding because I was able to see
people's comments and just like see the
impact I was making and because it was
so new and it was like a stretch for me
just to be sharing what's going on in my
life and just what I'm learning by
studying all this spiritual stuff I was
able to then like I was just writing
that flow writing that energy and I was
really passionate about it and it is
very important like people feel what you
feel and I'm very aware that the main
reason I believe people watch my videos
is not because of the concepts even
though I come up with new Concepts and
new ways to teach things and and stuff
like that from the books I read in just
my own life it's I realize at a certain
point that people were watching me
because of how it made them feel there
was an energy behind it the way I was
showing up because I was in my passion
they would feel that and then they would
get bought in and they would watch my
video videos every day because of how it
made them feel and I remember at a
certain point when I was committing to
the videos that one of the reasons I
committed to the Daily videos was back
in 2017 when I was working a sales job
selling women's shoes at Barney's New
York in Las Vegas and I knew I wanted to
be on YouTube I'd go on my lunch break
every day and I would uh like sit on my
lunch break and I would watch certain
YouTubers so I'd watch like Casey Nas uh
neistat I'd watch like these vloggers
and what I noticed is if they made daily
videos
every day it was a part of my routine so
Casey neistat Roman Atwood like these
some of the these younger guys but like
I just was so fascinated with like
how they were making daily videos how it
was getting me like hooked into their
lives and stuff and just their energy
and then what I did is I realized that
every if somebody stopped making daily
videos sometimes they'd kind of be out
of sight out of mind so I'd go on my
lunch break and then they weren't in my
field necessarily and I would fall off
but then what eventually happened is I
thought to myself what if I could be
that for other people so what if I made
a video every single day put it on
YouTube it was just kind of sharing you
know like the things I'm learning
working that sales commission job I
definitely could use like the Law of
Attraction and stuff because every day
you started at zero and then you you
know you had to sell and I could see the
different energy if I like had a certain
uh goal of hitting a certain goal
selling commission
um I could see how I would do with if I
went towards that goal with like really
serious and trying to hit it or if I
went towards it with the intention of
adding value to people that I was
helping or if I went in attention having
fun with the customers like I noticed
different energy shifts that would
happen and I would do a lot better when
I was having fun when I was enjoying
myself when I was like connecting with
people and not focused on just the money
and then I would share that in my
YouTube videos and then that was like
how I grew my channels I would just
share it was kind of like this relatable
guy that was like learning what I was
learning and um that was what I was
sharing on YouTube and then that's what
after like two or three months of making
videos I had some videos start to go
viral and uh then I was able to like
within six months quit my nine to five
job and and go full time and then figure
out internet marketing and all these
other things but it stemmed from
following that passion and where I'm at
now is I've been doing this for five
years
um I've run line of Live Events every
now and then but I'm realizing that like
there's an outdated I was talking to my
team about it yesterday we have like an
outdated Software System where like you
need to upgrade but it's kind of scary
to upgrade because certain things on
your computer will work differently Oh
you mean like on YouTube you need to
upgrade or like personally it's more of
an energetic realization like you know
on your computer like you might need to
upgrade to like a new software or a new
level but like it kind of sucks because
you're gonna have to get to use to
learning it and maybe you like the way
the old stuff works better I'm realizing
that within my life now because even
though I'm still somewhat passionate
about making videos
I feel like there's a whole new level
and when I like for example I had a
buddy and I come here to Austin to do a
live event recently and he asked me to
come speak at it and I was like at the
gym and I'm like okay
um I'll just I'll just go because I
don't have anything else to do and it'd
be fun it sounds like fun it sounds like
I I'd be passionate about just showing
up to his live event so I just showed up
to his live event and I had the
intention of only going on stage with
him for like 40 minutes to an hour
because I had some stuff to do
afterwards I was like oh 40 minutes
hours good I get there and I end up
being on stage for three hours we
brought people up we coach people it was
phenomenal the energy was insane
it was being recorded and I'm like oh
well now that's content I could be
putting on YouTube and it that was
assigned to me though that okay I tried
this different thing different than just
sitting in front of a video like making
content I did something new I pushed my
comfort zone even though like it's not
out of my comfort zone but I could just
tell I get lit up when I'm in front of
like a crowd when I'm live it challenges
me because you have to be able to read a
room you got to be able to it's a whole
different Beast yeah exactly yeah yeah
that's so cool so I'm like I'm thinking
it kind of reminds me of like even
Abraham Hicks style stuff yeah or like
even Teal Swan I mean they're they're
people that like do live like healings
or live work essentially with people
um so I'm curious what it is that you
feel like you want to bring to the stage
like what because they correct me if I'm
wrong but I do feel like part of the
purpose I mean you even say in the intro
like I help raise people's Consciousness
so uh expand people's Consciousness so
what is it that you want to deliver to
people from a stage that you is new like
what what what is what's in that in that
package that inspires you yeah that's uh
it's a good question because the that's
exactly what these last like because
I've taken a couple like even just a
week off of YouTube but I've been making
less content in general that's giving me
space to really go inwards to decide
like what is it that I'm really
passionate about sharing and like
helping people with and the the kind of
the underlying theme is kind of what
you're saying it's like help helping
people Elevate their level of
Consciousness raise their vibration is
kind of a new age kind of like a you
know an interesting term but in general
it's helping people Elevate their level
of awareness because I believe that
awareness is like the key to ninety
percent of transformation is awareness I
believe so the more aware you become of
the patterns in your life the more aware
you become of the belief systems that
you have the more aware you become of
the attachments of the the labels the
identity like the more aware you become
of all these things the more power you
take back to then like you know put in
life and
um at a live event what I like to do is
like help people become more aware of
these different aspects of themselves
that have been in the subconscious so
that normally happens through either
coaching people live on stage doing
group energy work another thing I'm
really passionate about that I've done
on YouTube and in different ways is I do
these uh like group meditations where we
activate our heart energies and we use
the power of group and tension to
transform our own lives and the planet
the you know like uh the ma I don't know
if you've ever heard of the Maharishi
effect it's it's similar to some of the
work Joe dispenzo is doing Dr Joe
dispenza but the Maharishi effect is
this like experiment that was done long
time ago and they re they replicate it
every so often where you get like 5 000
meditators around the world and they
focus on emoting an energy and setting
that intention
towards some specific thing so it could
be more love and peace or you know
whatever the energy is and they've
proven many times that when you get lots
of people focused on one outcome it
affects the planet in a way to where it
can decrease violent crimes on the
planet by up to like 70 percent for a
certain period of time and I'm not sure
if you've ever also the Schumann
resonance which is like the frequency of
the planet and when we do these I
remember one time may it was like May
5th like in 2020 I did this on YouTube
with 12 000 people
um that were like live at the same
moment and there were people around the
world doing this too so it wasn't just
me but we did that meditation where we
like connected into our hearts and you
know like uh connected to the group
energy which can become very powerful
and then what we did is we sent like uh
we tapped and like bring it in love and
and energy into our bodies and as we did
that there was like some people had some
very transformative experiences and I
could feel it too because I was like the
center point of like you know all those
people live and I could like feel that
energy but also the next day the
Schumann resonance which is like uh it's
like a way of gauging the frequency of
the planet it was it was all white like
it normally comes in fluxes it was all
white and it was like that's that's what
happens when people get together and
they meditate using the power of group
energy with a specific intention it can
powerfully change the planet and I think
what's happened in society is not to get
to I don't know like I don't know how
woo-woo this is but I believe that there
are people go ahead I mean I've had like
Elizabeth April on and teal and people
okay so you can do whatever the hell you
want well then I'll stretch it a little
bit I yeah I believe there are people
like I'm not a big conspiracy theory
person where I'm like in fear and all
this [ __ ] going on you know
um but in general I believe that it's a
known thing at certain levels that
there's this Collective Consciousness
that we're all connected to and I
believe that uh there are people that
maybe understand that if you keep people
in fear and in anger and in lower
vibrational emotions that their energy
is scattered right and that then it's
like they're much easier to control and
I think what's happening on the planet
right now is people are waking up
they're waking up to their own power
they're waking up to their uh like the
the ability for all of us to connect
together to create transformation on the
planet and I think that when we come
together together with group intention
like that it does the opposite of what
certain people may be doing to like keep
the collective Consciousness at a
certain level I mean when you look at
the media and the fear that's being
projected out into the world it's we're
so numb to it and so used to it but like
if you really sit down and think about
like just how much negativity is being
strung out in the media and stuff and
how there's a narrative and in a way of
thinking that really keeps people small
keeps people very subservient to like
everything in reality
um it's so it's silly to me it's like
wow it's like we people are so bought
into that and part of the work that I
tried to do my intention at least is to
help people wake up to them being like
understanding or maybe tapping into
their spiritual component that maybe
you're an eternal spiritual being living
a temporary Human Experience and maybe
when you come here you know you go
through crazy [ __ ] in life because and
especially early on in childhood because
I believe that that helps us to like
create pressure so that we can go
through a spiritual transformation or
through a spiritual awakening and uh
part of why I believe we came here deep
down even if we don't remember I think
as we came here to elevator level of
Consciousness to grow and to also come
together I know it sounds super [ __ ]
hippie you know but like to come
together so that we can really like
change the planet because I think that
the timeline that we may have been on
um in the past is is a timeline of like
destruction if you want to talk about
weirdness have you ever heard of Dolores
Cannon oh I love Dolores oh okay Dolores
oh Okay let's listen hours and hours and
hours and hours of Dolores she's amazing
that's awesome yeah that one thing that
really got me into this kind of content
was reading her books it was like the
con diluted Universe books I just love
like listening to some 80 year old woman
talk about the stuff she talks about so
matter-of-factly
um yeah with a grandma voice it's so
awesome
um but I feel like I've heard just about
everything that's out there on on
YouTube for her um that's how much a
listener so I probably should tap into
those books that's awesome yeah it's it
is something interesting about her just
because she does kind of have a she has
a grandma feel but she's talking about
these very esoteric things and she says
it you know she's she's had thousands
and thousands of people and deep levels
of hypnosis and it's not her saying it
it's not like I believe that you know
we're connect like ETS are real and I
believe this or that it's like these
this is what's consistently come through
thousands of people all over the world
who don't know each other they're not
like in a database like let's say this
on this hypnosis you know this deep
level of our subconscious mind let's
have this come through you know have you
ever looked into because she because one
of the things that she did was she
started teaching people how to go into
this deep deep state of hypnosis that
really nobody else was doing or at least
according to at that point in time
um to be able to go really deep into the
subconscious have you ever looked to see
if there's like a practitioner nearby or
someone that does her techniques oh yeah
my but my I have a buddy of mine that's
like uh he doesn't do sessions or
anything but he is certified like qhht
it's Quant it's called Quantum healing
hypnosis technique there it's a it's a
technique that even though she passed
away there's like a she has an
organization that trains people on how
to help people become like you know
certified in that to bring people
through past life regression or future
life regression or higher self whatever
they call it you know whatever anyone
wants to call it it's all I feel like
it's all kind of the same it's just what
name you give it exactly yeah they're
tapping into the subconscious mind and
there's information coming through one
of the interesting things I wanted to
share though about that is what they say
through some of the books the convoluted
Universe books is um which are just like
they're literally just transcripts of
her hypnosis sessions was that what
happened energetically back in the 1930s
is there were you know when the nuclear
bombs were going off and stuff what
happened is that was we were on a
timeline then of where the Earth could
possibly destroy itself because we were
experimenting with nuclear bombs and
when the nuclear bomb went off and they
were testing with it the thing is is
what she says and what people in her
hypnosis session say is that the way
Earth Works is we have free will here as
a collective to like decide what we
experience and what happened is when we
were experimenting with these nuclear
bombs it was going off and it was
Rippling out into the universe and it
was beginning to affect other reality
systems the rule is we are allowed to
affect our reality system but when we
begin affecting other reality systems
that's a No-No so what happened is uh
energetically there was like almost a
call put out to where we needed souls to
come to Earth to to Incarnate because
the rule with our reality is this Free
Will thing it's not like ETS can just
land and give us technology and we're
all fixed like we it has to come from
within the game itself and part of the
game of this reality is you come to
Earth you forget who you are there's a
veil of forgetfulness here you then go
through a process of remembering who you
are or you don't but there's an option
to like remember your spiritual nature
and who you are and then you wake up and
you go through different levels of
transformation now what happened is we
wanted like there was a call that was
put out so there were so many Souls that
felt such a deep connection to Earth
into this reality that we decided we
knew it was going to be hard to come
here to completely forget who we are to
then remember who we are
um but we knew that like we wanted to
help we wanted to help the planet come
onto a Higher timeline we we knew that
also now I believe that this and a lot
of text like a lot of ancient texts kind
of point to this time and Dolores Canon
material and other you know Abraham
Hicks and other channelers but in
general I believe right now is one of
the most important and like uh impactful
times to be alive ever on the planet
because there's there is a global shift
and Consciousness that is happening and
a lot of the [ __ ] that's coming to the
surface I believe is to help us become
more aware of like what's going on in
the collective Consciousness so that we
can clear it out and that pressure is
creating transformation so whether I
think people remember it or not I think
we forgot who we are to remember who we
are and we came here to play according
to the rules of life in a way to where
we forget to remember and then now we're
remembering and the more of us that come
together and remember this the more that
we're creating transformation on the
planet and the more that we're letting
go of old belief systems old power
dynamics and that's what's happening I
think in the political sense too it's
like things look very we're we're seeing
how silly like we've been running [ __ ]
for so long and we're able to like kind
of like let that come to fruition to
become aware of it
that now we can just like Let It Go and
and maybe move into some higher ways or
higher levels of of like interacting
both individually and collectively so
that's kind of you know the the
perspective that I really resonate with
is that we came here for this we may not
remember but and our purpose is to
really just be who we came here to be
like to really Elevate our own vibration
Elevate our own level of Consciousness
become aware and follow our passion and
that's kind of Loops into what we were
talking about in the beginning but like
the passion is the key following the
passion and knowing that when you're in
that energy state that is where more
probabilities and more synchronicities
come into our life you know like that's
why I know that when I start doing these
Live Events even if it's not
specifically the live events that bring
me like the abundance right away it's me
being in the energy state of doing the
live events that will Propel me to be in
a new energy to where then I perceive of
new synchronicities in my life that I
couldn't perceive of before because
before I was just in an old energy state
that brought me success for five years
but it's like it's not bringing me the
same energy anymore so I need to change
something and and that's why I know that
if I just follow this carrot on a stick
of like doing Live Events I'll figure it
out as I go maybe that is bigger
thousand person plus live events that
are like using group energy and stuff
maybe it's more so I do live events to
get content that I put on YouTube and
that grows the virtual audience you know
I don't know but I'll I know I'll figure
it out as I go from just being in that
state you know yes yeah trusting the
energy trusting the direction that it's
pulling you in that it is going to serve
the next purpose yeah um I think one of
the things that uh I totally agree with
all that by the way is people are
listening and they might they I'm if
they're still with us I'm sure that they
um they're they're totally jiving with
all this stuff but
um whether it's the person listening
that might not completely get it or
whether it's someone that they know that
might need it like how what is it that
gets people you mentioned at the
beginning like 90 is awareness right
when people talk about being like
feeling like kind of overwhelmed or
fresh frustrated or like there's a lot
going on and it's really difficult I'm
like you're so far much further along
than you realize the fact that you have
awareness to something you want to fix
yeah you people spend people literally
go through entire lives without ever
seeing the thing that needs to get fixed
and so the fact that you come to an
Awakening or a realization that you want
to change something is already so much
of the work so the real question I have
is like what does it take to get that
like what what can is that something
that could be manipulated meaning like
can you get people to that state or are
there like signs that people should look
out for that would sort of be a hook
into how they can heal patterns heal
relational patterns heal ancestral
patterns how do people get into that
space where they can have the awareness
because that to me seems like it takes
the longest I mean yes the alchemization
of energy to grow and expand like here's
the deal lessons are always hard like as
as many waves of it as I've gone through
I'm like this is so hard and and then
you're like [ __ ] it's because it's
another lesson and they're supposed to
be hard that's that's what it takes to
get to to to to shift it
um so how do we get people into
awareness uh the first thing I'll say is
everybody that is listening to this
right now
are so like already have to give
themselves credit because when people
are in the energy of like you know
consuming content that is about this
kind of stuff where it's we're talking
about awareness and transformation and
everything that you share on your
podcast they're already ahead of a large
percentage of the planet not that we
need to develop a spiritual ego about it
or anything but like it is it is true
like there are so many people that are
asleep and that are just in their
patterns and they're just like
completely kind of um immersed into that
to where they don't have they feel like
at least they don't have the ability to
like tap into that awareness so if
you're even able to perceive of this
episode right now then give yourself
credit because you are already on the
path if you know you're already looking
at yourself you're already uh on the
path of awareness and the key with
awareness that I found is
awareness is so simple it's just
observation it's observing what's
happening in your body it's it's
observing what's happening in the mind
and the best way that I've learned to do
that is through kind of what we're
talking about earlier where you take
space like I'm taking space for making
YouTube videos that's allowing me
Clarity it's taking space from life I
think a lot of times we are watching the
news we're watching social media we're
consuming we're consuming all these
things that may not be having the best
effect on our vibration or our energy
and then we're staying in the hamster
wheel so to gain awareness it's simply
asking yourself new questions like what
am I passionate about what do I believe
about what's like happening how do I
feel about it and another thing that
I'll share that like has been a
something that I share on my Channel
that I I hear people reach back to me
all the time and say this thing changed
my life and it's so simple
um I call it I I learned it from my
shadow work integration coach that I had
a while ago and it's a very simple
embodiment practice I call it the frame
technique so I have like a video on
YouTube called the frame technique and
it's a yep it's a very simple process us
but it literally is bringing the
awareness into the body and feeling the
separation between you and like a candle
flame or you in the wall are you in the
computer right now if you bring the
awareness into your body
and you feel the separation between you
and another object are you and another
person if you have somebody that you're
you you have trouble setting boundaries
with other people
and you feel like maybe or maybe there's
like an X that you're you want to let go
of or something what you can do is bring
the awareness into the hands bring the
awareness into the feet and actually
focus on the separation between you and
this other person and and in the
spiritual Community there's this like
we're all connected let's all feel
connected but that is only one side of
the equation a lot of what spiritual
people need I believe is actually to
feel separation because in the
separation you're able to actually feel
safe in your own body and you're able to
delineate this is me and that is you and
even though we're all connected that's
where people get where they feel like
they're not able to tap into the
awareness is because they feel so pulled
into so many different directions like
what does my mom want me to do what is
my boyfriend and girlfriend want me to
do my husband wife what does my kids
want me to do or they're trying to
please everybody and then you don't know
who the [ __ ] you are or for empaths or
highly sensitive people exactly and
that's who that frame technique helps
the most is empaths it's people that
feel so connected to everybody else and
what that I found and I talk you know
this is something I've learned from my
own life is that's being an empath I
believe is somewhat of a learned
mechanism that has been birthed because
of trying to get your own needs met so
for example growing up as a kid I was
someone like this because I had to like
in order to get the approval or
validation as a kid I had to tune to my
environment to feel safe so part of
being an empath is tuning to other
people and feeling like into what
they're feeling because then it's like
if I can make you happy or if I can
please you or let the tension go away
and avoid tension and you feel good then
I can feel good so it's a mechanism that
was learned as a kid to ease tension to
then get other people to feel a certain
way so then I could say oh now I can
feel safe and the problem with that
though is that then when you tune to
other people that often uh what ends up
happening is you lose your sense of self
you lose what I call your frame your
sense of frame and feeling safe in your
own frame and being able to set
boundaries with other people being able
to feel and live according to your own
values because as a people pleaser or an
empath you tune to other people and your
values become their values whatever they
value like I value that too and you're
like who the [ __ ] am I you know what do
I value what's important to me and
that's why I think it's very important
this whole frame technique uh process of
just bringing the awareness in your body
is then you could start saying like what
do I actually value in my life and what
I had to realize to shed that people
pleaser Persona is I valued as the old
version of me I valued validation and
approval from other people that were
like my top values I wasn't aware of it
but I became aware that oh wait I really
want people to like me I really want
people to like feel good around me and I
then became aware that I was living by
those values to get my inner childhood
needs met that where it meant of
validation and approval and then I
became aware of how much that was
actually hurting me I became aware that
in dating I was dating women where I
felt like I had to fix them or I had to
please them or and and then that was
making the masculine feminine energy
Dynamic not very grounded and that was
not good for the relationship and I
noticed that my dad my I got it from my
dad my dad's like a typical nice guy
that he attracted my ex-stepmom who was
a narcissist and that was the dynamic
that I saw
and so it's a trap that a lot of people
fall into unfortunately but yeah it was
uh I could see how it never as a nice
guy or a people pleaser you think if I
do this strategy I'm gonna get my needs
met but it actually doesn't really work
because people don't respect you and
then you feel like you're getting pulled
in different directions but I decided
instead of living according to
validation and approval I'm gonna live
according to the values of vulnerability
and authenticity and the thing with
vulnerability is that's the ability to
like show the real you so people please
there's an empaths are afraid of showing
their real emotions they're afraid of
being vulnerable they're afraid you know
back in the day I'd be afraid to like
show someone I was dating that I was
attracted to them and what I learned
after like this transformation is like I
now Express that I express that desire I
express my true emotions I don't hold it
back and it has a completely different
effect on masculine and energy masculine
feminine energy Dynamics and what I
realized is like that it takes
vulnerability to ask somebody out it
takes vulnerability to show your your
own emotions and to show how you really
feel and when someone says something you
don't like to like say hey I don't think
that was cool it takes vulnerability to
do that and the big the main wound of
the empath of the people pleaser is an
abandonment wound where they're afraid
other people are going to leave and the
way out of the abandonment wound is
actually into vulnerability it's into
being able to let go of the shame which
means I'm broken the shame is like
that's what people are hiding that have
that people pleaser nice guy persona
they're trying to hide the belief that
I'm broken but when you're able to show
the real you and live according to that
vulnerability it's it's uh it takes
courage but as you do it you start
rewiring your sense of beliefs of who
you are and your own sense of worthiness
and you start realizing you actually are
worthy and that's what changed my life
more than anything was valuing
vulnerability and authenticity over
validation and approval and becoming
aware of my own values what do I choose
to live by those values plus other
values
um following my passion and you know
things like that and that's completely
transformed my life but it's come
through feeling separation between me
and other people more than anything and
that's helped me feel safe in my frame
and it's completely changed like how I
show up it's completely changed my
masculine like how I show up in my in my
own energy in so many different ways
well that was beautiful and well said
and yes there's such a difference
between Attunement and absorption
yeah I like to decide to attune to
someone is can be beautiful but
absorption of energy is confusing you
never know where you start and end
compared to someone else you know as
you're talking about
um the abandonment wound on the other
side of the coin would be like more of
the avoidant or narcissist someone on
the other side of the spectrum but the
thing is is that it's actually like very
much a similar original wounds it's you
know the The Narcissist also wants to
doesn't believe they're good enough and
they put they put a facade or a mask on
and they just kind of push people away
um instead of people pleasing and you
know that's the funny thing about life
is that you know it's part of the same
whole like everything's a circle it's
not an end-to-end thing it's just the
other side of a circle and that it's the
original wound is is very similar it's
just not being not having your emotional
needs met and that people just have
different ways of dealing with them but
we're all trying to correct that
original wound of wanting to be seen so
what I mean I want to get into
relationships because I feel like
they're just like they're so they're so
hard yeah they feel so hard like what
the hell are they for because they are
so hard like let's just start there okay
why are relationships difficult ultimate
relationships I mean any relationship
can be but let's just like circle around
intimate right now I guess yeah I mean I
think relationships can be so hard
because they bring up our own childhood
wounding that maybe we aren't aware of
because because when we're Ki I believe
when we're kids we have a certain way
that we relate to our parents and we
have certain meanings and when we're
like born to about seven to nine years
old we're primarily in Theta State and
then Theta State a brainwave activity
we're literally absorbing the belief
systems the energies and the patterns of
our environment and normally up to that
age including the years before I mean oh
yeah would say Bruce Lipton would say
it's from like the last trimester in the
womb still until you know sort of that
seven year you know seven years old or
so like all of that you're absorbing you
think that yelling in front of your baby
in the crib is not going to do anything
because they won't remember but they're
actually like storing that [ __ ] at a
hyper level yeah I think about it I
think it's sometimes like a scenario
we're like I've seen it before at a
grocery store where like parents are
with the little kid and the little kid
doesn't want to go somewhere and they're
like okay bye bye as if they're gonna
leave the kids and there's a little joke
but I'm like that kid is literally
absorbed and starts crying because it
thinks his parents are just gonna leave
him or her in the middle of a store you
know so it's kind of a funny example but
every like little things can very much
impact
uh those that the parts of our identity
and when we're born up until like you
know seven to nine or whatever but like
yeah to even not even born like in the
trimester like in our in our mom you
know
um we're absorbing belief systems and
patterns and energies and the thing is
is one thing that we're trying to like
we're subconsciously I believe trying to
do in our relationships is we're trying
to kind of close the loop from childhood
we're trying to close the loop and and
kind of like heal and we find partners
that replay normally very familiar
energy Dynamics from when we were kids
you're somebody that had maybe a
controlling mom or dad then you may
either adopt certain patterns yourself
or you might attract you might just
naturally be attracted to people that
have that same type of familiar safe
energy and that's like some in
relationship that's where it comes out
like it comes out through intimate
relationships that's where emotional
availability comes into play and then
the different strategies that we have in
order to give and receive love from like
7 to 15 I had that narcissistic stepmom
in my life uh my dad finally divorced
her after my ex-step mama left my life
when I was 15 years old
um I then had all this freedom I was
able to have friends because I didn't
have friends before that I wasn't
allowed to you know I'd like kind of
earn going to school activities and
stuff and then I have all this freedom I
have all it's like a whole new reality
but what ended up happening is I I kept
attracting women into my life that were
very controlling so I attracted an
ex-girlfriend that was very jealous and
insecure and trying to always control
everything I was doing and what ended up
happening is she was in my life for like
four years I didn't end the the way the
relationship ended wasn't necessarily me
ending it it kind of like stuff happened
and then it had to end that was the
pattern that I kind of learned you just
kind of stay in it as long as you
absolutely have to yeah then eventually
when that breakup did happen I then got
transferred to a better department when
I worked at a certain woman's shoe
department I got transferred to Designer
Shoes which is like more money the
manager of that department was the same
exact energy Dynamic of my ex-stepmom
literally like to a t she was
controlling manipulative she couldn't
physically like obviously do anything
but like emotionally and the way she
would talk to us she was protected by
upper management so we couldn't get her
fired you know uh like she was in my
life for like five years while I was
working that sales job like three to
five years and then what happened is I
went through my Spiritual Awakening in
2012 and what happened is I ended up
like forgiving my ex-stepmom through I
learned meditation and I learned I
started seeing like what my ex stepmom
did is I could see that she was treated
the same way by her dad and that's why
she learned that pattern and she was
like doing the best she could from the
level of Consciousness she was at it
didn't necessarily make it right but it
did help me understand her more and then
I ended up forgiving her and within two
weeks of forgiving her that manager got
fired which was crazy because for like a
year we tried getting her fired because
she do this crazy [ __ ] but she was like
protected by upper management and we
like we couldn't get her fired and then
within two weeks of me forgiving her
um she got fired it's like she
energetically left my life because it
didn't resonate with my energy anymore
I'd learned the lesson or I'd forgiven
and it wasn't active in my field and
that was like trippy for me because what
if you know it sounds kind of
egotistical for me to say there were
like 12 other people in that department
but the moment I healed that energy
Within Myself
that person like that energy then left
my life and I've never dated someone
that was narcissistic like that or had
someone in my life like that ever again
because I think I I'm too I'm aware of
the energy I I notice it within seconds
like I've I when I meet people like not
that I'm trying to just judge people and
say oh this person's narcissists but I
can very quickly tell someone's
intentions within within a couple
minutes of meeting people and I just
choose not to like interact or get
intertwined with people that do have
that energy Dynamic alive amazing
there's a lot of healing that comes
through in relationship especially
intimate as you know we're getting poked
at our deepest most vulnerable points
and we're we're we're trying so hard to
make those work
um but what about like what about the
healing within so there's like the
masculine and feminine essentially with
a relationship but then what about the
one within you what about your own
masculine feminine balance and energy
how important do you think that is to
the whole puzzle of being in a balanced
intimate relationship
I think it is I think it's very
important I think that we attract
Partners based on the energy that we're
embodying
so if like I noticed that in the past
um if I wasn't in my true like masculine
energy I would attract people that would
have that activated within themselves
and then it almost like we'd be
competing for the masculine spot so we'd
have to like kind of like merge back and
forth and and it was an and it was an
interesting energy that I became like
aware of and
one thing that I think happens when we
go through a spiritual awakening that
Carl Yoon talked about is called the
anima and the Animus and the anima and
the Animus is the personality like
structure within ourselves where once we
go through a spiritual awakening we kind
of shift to the other side to then heal
it and so for for a lot of times women
May shift into more of uh their their
masculine side because deep down there's
like a a desire to learn that and to
heal that energy and for men they'll go
into their feminine side that's why when
you see a lot of like spiritual dudes
you might see like some spiritual hippie
dudes that like are very feminine energy
and it's it's kind of a natural stage
that people go through some people stay
there for a long time but you also see
you know a lot of like uh you know women
that go through Spiritual Awakening that
then are like women's empowerment and
and energy like that and there's nothing
wrong with any of it but it's very
important to understand kind of like why
you're what you're going into that
energy and to understand where your core
is the because I think sometimes people
go through some type of trauma where
they may have gone through something
where maybe they have a masculine wound
or a feminine wound and then they take
on the energy themselves and they feel
figure they need to embodyment because
their needs aren't being met and that is
kind of also a strategy that's been
created to not really surrender to the
masculine or the feminine so for example
someone may say well it wasn't safe for
me around the masculine growing up uh
because my dad was kind of toxic or this
person was kind of toxic so I'm gonna
activate that energy Within Myself and
I'm going to grow my business and be
focused on all these masculine
perspectives because that's where I find
safety I don't need anybody else because
when I needed dad back in the day or I
needed masculine energy back in the day
it wasn't provided for and I didn't feel
seen and heard so I don't need it and
then it's like an energy of
um you know kind of fulfilling that role
within themselves but then they they
attract people that maybe aren't in
their masculine energy or they track
people that are more feminine because
it's playing off that energy that's
being embodied so part of the work is
really going into that energy and and
becoming aware of the the kind of like
the mini trauma that may have happened
or that the association the belief about
the masculine and feminine energy and
then uh learning to surrender more to
that so if somebody wants to attract a
more masculine partner then it's like
them softening in their feminine energy
or if they're a guy and they want to
attract a more feminine woman or
whatever the dynamic is as far as like
sexuality goes but then it's it's to
embody more directionality you know the
masculine is very directional it's very
penetrative it's going in a specific
Direction and I see sometimes a lot that
there's there's men that may not they
don't know where they're going they're
they're very flowy State there's nothing
wrong with it but when you when you get
more into that directional energy you
feel more masculine and you feel more
grounded and that's really what the
feminine wants the feminine wants to
feel safe in the masculine directional
energy
and and wants to feel safe and seen and
heard and not fixed you know it's what
the feminine wants more so and then the
masculine just wants to feel appreciated
wants to feel appreciated and and
um like nurtured you know so it's kind
of understanding those energies within
themselves I went through a phase where
I had to heal the mother wound in a way
where you know I felt like I didn't
receive a lot of nurturing growing up
um I knew my mom was going through a lot
of stuff when I was a baby because her
dad passed away and stuff so
um when she was young when I was like
three and she went through a whole
process so I had to learn kind of like
how to relate to the feminine in a
different way and I had to learn that a
lot of the stuff that I experienced
growing up the shame and the belief I
was broken absorbing kind of my mom
stuff I had to realize that that wasn't
mine that it wasn't my fault it wasn't
because I wasn't good enough yeah
um and once I realized that and I was
able to kind of separate the energy and
realize that a lot of that nice guy
people pleaser Persona wasn't even mine
it was my dad's and my mom's energy and
then I was able to get into who I choose
to be and how I choose to embody energy
and that was life-changing for me
because I realized that I'm not the
result of my past I'm not my mom and my
dad's energies and I felt free have you
had to address a father wound yeah for
sure okay because I was gonna say like
part of my journey has been like
thinking it was the father wound and
then realizing that actually the one
that holds the the most amount of power
and transformation was the mother I just
didn't it wasn't so obvious to me it
sounds like that was maybe how your dad
was with you where it seemed like the
mom was sort of the inflammatory sort of
like ingredient to the situation and
yeah and so I thought that was kind of
my dad and then I realized that the
ultimately none of it changes until I
hear heal the mother one because that's
how I acted like I realized I acted like
my mom and I can't until I change how I
think feel and act my reality can't
change and so it was actually the mother
wound that ended up being the one that
that
stops the father connection those
relationships being attracted to me that
were like my Dad wow yeah well that's a
powerful Insight it was brutal Insight
it was like an emotional brutal insight
and it's still a lot of work but but
yeah I um that was uh that was a big
part of it as far as relationships go I
love asking the question of people
um and it sounds kind of like such a
cynic or something but uh what's the
point why why why why why get married
why why be in a relationship why why try
and find someone for the rest of your
life we look at it like this thing
that's supposed to you find the one
person for the rest of your life and you
stay together and it's bad if you you
know breakups are sad and and that's
sort of like some sign of some kind of
level of failure in some way I don't
think that everyone always looks at it
like that and we're growing but but like
the idea would be and I still feel this
way it's like when do I find someone
that you know like stands the test of
time and that we grow together and
instead of a part or one grows in the
other doesn't and but is that even what
I should be looking for or now that we
live to a hundred or you know soon
enough it'll be 120 or talk to Dave
aspirin it's 180.
um you know is it likely is it realistic
that we're supposed to be with somebody
for 50 60 70 years yeah that's a that's
a very uh interesting good question
because I think it's it's also questions
that I ask myself sometimes too you know
I think when it comes to relationships
for myself at least the purpose of it
for me is growth because I have grown
more like I I've I've been able to like
create a lot of success in my life
through YouTube and putting myself out
there and following my passion but I
grow way more in relationships like I
grow way more through relationships and
maybe because it's it hits so much
deeper closer to home but some of my
most suffering most challenging moments
have been through breakups or
relationships yeah and I think that you
know there's like sayings that like you
know it's one thing to go meditate in a
cave for like 20 30 years but try like
living with somebody and having all
these different things rub up against
each other like I think the purpose of
it for me and maybe for you know I think
it's a way that we exponentialize our
spiritual growth and it's the way we
look at our inner childhood needs that
maybe weren't met and we learned how to
like we learned how to get have those
needs met through ourself and others and
how we relate to other people so
connection and growth for me is like
what I notice I I grow more through that
and as as far as like the being with one
person forever I question that too
sometimes but I wonder how much of that
comes from my own upbringing because
I've seen my dad go through two divorces
with my mom and then my ex-stepmom and
I've seen the pain that that causes and
I've seen my mom go through like
breakups and stuff and I you know I have
like my best friend him and his wife
have been together 15 years and his
parents are like his mom and dad are
still together her mom and dad are still
together his wife who's a great friend
of mine and it's like I wonder sometimes
like how much of that is like their
belief is that like relationships last
forever and am I wounded because my
parents weren't together so maybe my my
notion is that like oh it probably won't
eventually I'll get tired of it or it
won't work out or and I wonder if that's
just my experience my belief system and
the thing that I'm looking to do is to
really go into that and to kind of learn
as I go and not put too much pressure on
a specific like relationship and and to
like assume oh it's a lot of pressure to
say oh this needs to last until 100 or
180 years old you know I've been
learning to take things more in the
moment and to see the person that I'm
dating or the person I'm spending time
with as like as like uh uh is it just
something that I can share for as long
as it lasts and learn from it and not
have that expectation of how long it's
going to last but
um just kind of like learn as I go and I
think I'm redefining what that is is as
I go so in like 10 years maybe and I am
like oh I want to be you know with one
person my whole entire life but I think
that we have many soul mates in our life
and I think that maybe in that like
talking about the Dolores Cannon stuff
maybe you know we in higher dimensions
and higher realities we may live like
800 years old you know right it's like
we we may it's not we may shift through
different you know life partners and
seasons and things like that so I don't
know the answer to be honest you know
what do you what do you think it's just
such an interesting thing to contemplate
well yeah yeah I mean thanks for asking
I I you know when you say my belief and
my what I'm here to do in this life is
to grow and evolve like I believe
fundamentally that is the point and what
I wonder is if
relationships bring in the highest
potential to move through those spaces
and grow does that mean that they will
be grown out of because they are
attracted for a certain Dynamic to heal
once that's healed then you move on like
I'm wondering if that's just literally
the dynamic of the situation with a
relationship is like do you if you grow
you kind of grow past them because they
are an old pattern and then I wonder
like is it just your orientation with
the self do I need to create that
relationship with myself and then you
know in an Abraham Hicks style you know
wording like you can I can use that
person my partner as my point of
attention for all the positive and like
nothing could change that like the that
I could use them for all of it and um
instead of focusing on the negative or
the bad and maybe it's just meant to be
uh you know maybe then you're able to
move through life with someone if you if
you don't choose to look at the negative
in someone and you have that
um have a certain relationship with the
self and that's kind of where I wonder
about the masculine and feminine within
each one of us being a critical element
to a real Union a real Union yeah the
one that is hormone the Harmony the one
that does last the one that that one can
flow through events and challenges
um because you're not using them as your
growth and you're not using them as
um you know you're not uh you're not
moving past them so it there is no I
don't have an answer I just yeah I have
questions more than anything so I my I
mean most of my life is spent sort of
um philosophizing about stuff with my
friends and family and people so I just
love to ask these questions and I know
that there's probably not necessarily an
answer but the way that we figure it out
is through talking about it and I'm just
generally curious but they do they do
hold a lot of power and um and I do seek
them and so so yeah it's interesting
um maybe we should talk about
Consciousness just a little bit
um you know since you you know talk
about expanding people's Consciousness
I'm curious like what what do you what
is consciousness to you well it's funny
because I say I I've said in like
thousands of YouTube videos now like my
name is Aaron and I help people expand
their Consciousness yep their
Consciousness is I I don't think it is
something that can actually be expanded
because it is like it just is like
Consciousness is like awareness it just
is but I guess it's more like expanding
awareness because when you expand your
scope of awareness like I know there's
like a saying that when you're looking
through like uh golf Souls size hole you
have like a golf golf ball size
Consciousness but if you expand it you
then see way more you know so I think
Consciousness and awareness it just kind
of is
um and the what we're doing is we're
we're becoming more aware of the
subconscious parts of ourselves or the
patterns and the energies and as we do
that that's when our life really changes
when we become aware of those
attachments or become aware of the
energy that we're living in you know
when I was working a nine-to-five jobs
on women's shoes I I energetically knew
okay I'm working my thoughts my actions
my emotions everything was incomplete I
was in complete alignment with that
version of me you know but then I became
aware I'm like oh wait I see myself and
I am embodying like a somebody that
works a nine-to-five job I am letting
someone tell me what to do I'm not
taking initiative I had to start taking
initiative as like making videos and
like building something apart from my
nine-to-five job it required a different
level of Consciousness a different level
of awareness so in general just to kind
of summarize I think it's something that
already exists and it's the the more
aware we become the more than we're able
to like see how we're thinking feeling
and acting and then we can more so look
at ways of embodying the energies of
what we want to create because for me to
become a full-time YouTuber what I did
is I literally just decided to be a
full-time YouTuber my thoughts my
emotions and my actions were all aligned
to what would a full-time YouTube tuber
version of Aaron B doing and I said I'm
not going to wait till I have a hundred
thousand subs and people tell me my
videos are good or I have all this like
you know success in my life for me to
like share what I'm doing I'm going to
just decide that the moment I start it I
am it so the moment I started making
videos I started seeing myself as a
full-time YouTuber and then within weeks
my whole entire life changed so is that
a visual visualization technique it was
like how when you say that
um like if some like what would you tell
someone to do I would tell them to go
into a meditation begin to tap into
using the power of your imagination
connect to you could call it your higher
self your higher mind or God or whatever
label you want to give it but ask
yourself like what does the version of
me that is the most passionate version
of me that is the highest vibrational
version of me or whatever what does that
version of me doing on a daily basis how
is that version of me showing up
and through your power of your
imagination you can begin to get Clues
as to what that is and for me I was
living at my dad's house working that
sales job selling women's shoes and for
me I I did this meditation where I
imagined it and I saw that that version
of me is making daily videos and
literally this sounds but I felt like I
got a message from my higher self or
whatever that said if you make a video
every single day on YouTube your life
will transform so I said okay no matter
what every single day I'm gonna make a
video until I'm full-time like just
because this is who I choose to be but
also because that it'll change my life I
believed it so I made a video every
single day and I made it from the energy
of not of once I make a hundred thousand
once I have a hundred thousand Subs then
I'm a YouTuber like I saw myself and was
being a full-time YouTuber I was
modeling the thoughts the feelings the
actions to that version of me I could
tell that that version of me is a
full-time YouTuber uh had to like learn
how to make thumbnails I had to learn
marketing I had to learn how to
um like there were all these things I
didn't know at the time when I first
made my first video but that was like oh
I need to learn marketing I need to
learn how to make thumbnails I need to
learn how to edit I edited all my videos
the first couple months of like the
first six months of making videos I
edited all my own videos so I had to
learn how to do that you know and
um
like the the main message I have though
is to start because once you start and
you take on the identity and the beliefs
of that that's who you are now and it's
important to be it because you choose to
be it not be it because it's going to
help you escape
a side effect of me being that full-time
YouTuber was that I could eventually
quit my nine-to-five job but when people
want to be a YouTuber because they want
views they want money that a lot of
times I I find is you're making it a
means to an end and not an end of itself
like I had to I and that's why now it's
like I'm realizing that the beingness of
being a YouTuber is like outdated for me
and I want to do Live Events now so I'm
aware of that energy but in general you
want to be it because it's who you
choose to be and when you're in that
energy it's very different than being it
because of what it'll get you or like or
something like that I've had things I've
learned in the past about like things I
could do online to make money before I
was on YouTube and I would do it I would
give up because I wasn't really
passionate about it right but once I
then like did some I my heart lit my
heart up on fire it's like the universe
rewards that the Universe in a way is
going to reflect back the energy that
you're embodying so one of the biggest
like lessons I teach on my YouTube
channel and all my content is every Mo
quantum physics is showing us that every
moment's a new moment that every moment
the the cells in our body are dying and
being reborn And if every moment's a new
moment every moment you're a new version
of you you can be who you choose to be
the only thing that keeps you held back
is your story it's the story about who
you are it's the story I'm Aaron I work
a nine to five job that I don't enjoy
but I feel like I have to it's a story
it's a belief and you can let go of it
at any moment and once you become aware
that it's a belief and it's a story you
can then choose something new because
every moment you're a new you so every
moment you're a new you and every moment
you're a new you why would you keep
telling yourself the same story over and
over again once you're aware that it's a
story it was never built in reality that
Aaron Dowdy is a you know a shoe sales
person or whatever like I realized that
that was just something I agreed to that
was on autopilot and once I became aware
of that
and then shifted the energy and I
started to embody a full-time YouTuber
version of myself that meant I was
sometimes working in Vegas we sometimes
I would work till 11 or 12 at night
because I worked on the strip and I
would get home at like one in the
morning I would film a video edit the
video schedule the video to go out the
next day
and I did that so not not all the time
you know I would get ahead on videos but
there were a couple times I had to do
that because it was a part of my
identity and people would ask me Aaron
how are you able to make so many videos
on YouTube it was easy because it's a
part of my identity I was like what do
you mean it's like it's like if I if you
were to go to the gym and I know you
work out and stuff so like imagine the
first time somebody ever goes to the gym
and they're like oh my God it's so hard
to go to the gym and then they do it
again and then they do it again and
after a month they're like their
identity shifted they're like it's like
is it hard for you to go to the gym
you're like no I'm just I'm a gym goer
like I go to the gym or I do yoga or
whatever that is it's easy once it
clicks into your identity and for me I
was being a YouTuber and then all these
other YouTubers were making one video a
week two videos a week like how are you
able to make seven videos a week that's
crazy and it was easy because it was a
part of my identity it was the way
it was the way and now it's gonna be
coming outdated you know now I'm like
okay that's what I want to know okay
what's the what's the update
well the update now is that
um my identity is Shifting like I I am
there's a there's a fear that comes with
letting go of just making so many videos
on YouTube because it's brought me so
much success but I have to let go of
that version of me in order to like
become and to put my energy into this
new version of me of doing Live Events
of putting my energy there with my team
and and into that kind of energy because
at one time I had to let go of being a
full-time of being a full-time you know
shoe sales person right I had to let
that go and that was scary too even
though I was more excited about making
videos it's like I get paid 60 70k a
year to like sit around in a suit sell
shoes and this thing the first year I
think I I made close to that I made
maybe 50k I made less than I made the
first year in 2017 and then after that
everything exponentialized because I I
became I learned internet marketing and
I I learned all these different things
then my channel blew up to over a
million subscribers and when that
happened there were more opportunities
but now the fear is letting go of the
and I'm not completely letting it go
because I'll still have videos but like
in the way that I've related to it I
have to let that go and I have to I feel
like I get to really like wire in a new
version of me that is like doing events
every month or something like that even
if it's just small at first I might just
do it just to get my energy into it do
like 50 people like 50 person live event
like here in Austin like with no
pressure literally just do it to make
content to have like someone on my team
is like an expert at like you know all
the tech stuff
um so like if at a live event he records
everything and you know I can Replay
that energy onto YouTube and stuff so
what I could do is have you know
everything recorded and put that on
YouTube and because I'll be in a
different energy State I think it will
do not only you know and it's not even
it shouldn't be an attachment to mine
that it has to do as good as the old
stuff but there needs to be the
awareness that like I can't I need to
like to wire this new me I need to be a
new me I need to be this me that is more
passionate more in my heart and let go
of the attachments of the familiar
energy the hamster wheel that I've
created you know even it's a nice it's a
much better hamster wheel than the nine
to five job goer version of me but it's
still a hamster wheel that I feel caught
in sometimes you know how does this uh
how does this story end for in your mind
the story of your lifetime and the
planet and this Great Awakening and
everything like write the story for how
you hope it will go from a you know from
your standpoint and from a collective
standpoint
yeah
um I I believe that as time goes on and
talk about the collective
uh first the I believe that as time goes
on right now what's happening is a form
of initiation
there is you know when we go through as
an individual many of us that have been
through spiritual Awakenings have gone
through a lot of pressure early on in
life
that has allowed us pressure to then
create like a new dimension to ourselves
whether that's the spirituality that
kind of connection and what's happening
at a collective level is everything is
getting shaken up and there's a lot of
pressure that's being created there's a
lot of fear and a lot of lower
vibrational emotions that are being
evoked and what I think is coming out of
this is more and more people are waking
up more and more people are waking up to
questioning their reality questioning
the the way things are ran questioning
the fear and all this energy that's
being projected
um and as people are questioning it
they're starting to question like what
do they believe who are they why did
they come here you know people like back
in the day I think people would you know
work like eight fifty years and work
jobs they freaking hated and that was
the norm and now people like they're not
settling for that and when you look at
like you know like your podcast or my
YouTube channel the reason it grows is
because more and more people are waking
up I think there's more and more of a
demand for this and more than ever I
believe what's going to continue to
happen is not only are people going to
wake up but like the people that are
listening to us right now I believe that
they are the the Leading Edge Of
Consciousness and the Leading Edge of
them embodying their true power their
true energy and that by them being that
version of themselves that's what
transfer forms the planet it starts with
us and then collectively the more we
follow our passion the more we become
aware of these patterns within ourselves
the more we release the stuck energy
inside of our bodies the more we Elevate
our own frequency our own vibration and
that changes the planet and I truly
believe that within the next uh 50 to
100 years I believe that even the next
10 15 years I believe life will continue
to exponentialize and change in many
ways I believe that eventually
um we'll have like first Contact I
believe that ETS exist and I believe
that the government's known about it for
a very long time I believe that that
will be common knowledge in I believe it
kind of already is but it will be more
so common knowledge over the next 10 15
years I believe eventually we'll we'll
be looking into like the planet more and
just how much harm we're doing to the
oceans and [ __ ]
um I believe there'll be technology that
cleans a lot of that up that maybe we
find or create I believe that more
people will be following their passions
and doing what they love and they won't
be working jobs that they hate right I
mean there there's a lot of different
layers to it but for me it's like I just
want to embody the highest vibrational
version of me that I can and that means
that the version of me that's more like
in my heart and more passionate and more
emotionally available and more uh
expressive in whatever way that looks
like but I believe that this is the most
exciting time to be alive ever I believe
that at the end of this life we'll have
you know we'll we'll be able to really
connect to higher levels if we want or
you know stay here I don't know I think
it's exciting time that we live in right
now and that more transformation will
happen the next 10 20 40 years and we
could even possibly imagine you know I
agree I agree well I want you to know
that you're on it like you're totally on
that path and you've been even though
like every iteration of growth feels
like oh man it's like you you've been
doing it you've been doing the work and
thank you for sharing that with people
and
um it's it's working that's all I can
say it's working so thank you and thank
you for what you do and thank you for
like all the energy you put on in the
world because you have such a a great
energy and I can just tell that you're
making a big difference and you're
you're bringing this kind of awareness
and energy to like an audience that I
think is
um like it's very beneficial and I think
it's it's cool the way you're bridging
these these different realities together
and I think you do it in a very level of
high integrity and like you're you're
just you're also I've hung out with you
before and it's a very interesting and
awesome person you're you're great in
real life too so thank you for being
here and everything you're doing
hopefully we connect again soon yeah I
look forward to it thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button